all right we are live it is 11 a.m
eastern on february 9
2022 and hello to all of you wise people
who are tuning in to the reuben report
direct message hosted by dave rubin
instead of watching the lunatics on the
view
on abc right now you've made the right
choice and i promise
not to let you down uh of course we are
live streaming on rumble on youtube and
on blaze tv if you could subscribe tap
notification bell all that sort of stuff
it would be appreciated uh and you know
we got incredible feedback yesterday
from the show we did something that we
had sort of never really done here
before which is do a sort of narrative
show that we didn't really cover four
or five stories as we normally do but it
was a through-line show for about 40
minutes sort of tracing what has
happened related to joe rogan and the
rumble situation and why the media is
going after him and the inauthentic
apologies and how cancel culture makes
people do all sorts of weird things that
they know deep down ain't right but
everybody's got their own stuff that
they're dealing with um and i really
felt when we ended the show i was like i
want to do more of that that was good it
felt dense and real
to me uh i'm
give a full shout out to phoenix our new
associate producer who helped put that
together and we thought we could do a
little bit more of that kind of stuff
we're not going to do it all the time
but today we are going to do a similar
show in that you can see right now how
the media and the democrats are really
shifting when it comes to the covid
narrative you can really feel it if
you're paying attention to what's online
suddenly like this shift to like oh we
do want to open schools and we do want
you out of masks and we don't want any
more lockdowns and we never were really
for all of those things and you can see
them doing it in real time and the
reason that they're doing it is because
the midterms are coming all the polling
is showing that the republicans are
going to win uh the house in a landslide
maybe even the senate that there could
be a whole bunch of other massive shifts
and the democrats are realizing that
people don't like these horrific
authoritarian policies so we're going to
give you a through line for the next
half hour of sort of how we got here
where we were where we're going and
we're going to relate it to everything
happening right at this very moment so
sit back
get your coffee or your tequila or
whatever you're drinking and uh let's do
this thing so where this all started
in the last couple days where the shift
really started was that stacy abrams who
is the woman who lost the georgia
gubernatorial race a couple years ago
was speaking to a classroom of children
and this image leaked out here's stacy
abrams and oh my god look at her sitting
indian style with such a big
smile on her face and as you can see she
is not masked
but all the children are mass that seems
odd i mean
she's no offense a rather large woman
and that is one of the main cobor
comorbidities when it comes to covid but
putting aside that
this image this really horrific i mean
this joking aside this is a really
horrific image look what they have done
to children and this [ __ ] eating grin
that this woman has as she sits there
with all of these masked children who
are at no risk to each other who are at
no risk to the teachers etc etc and we
all know this and they keep
doing it okay now stacy abrams what's
interesting about her is nobody really
knows anything about this woman other
than the media loves her and as i said
she lost the gubernatorial race in
georgia which by the way she uh didn't
really concede you may have remembered
that yeah why stacey abrams is still
saying she won so democrats are allowed
to contest elections they're allowed to
question election authority and they're
allowed to you know go oh maybe it
wasn't legit that's cool when
republicans do it insurrection evil
arrest these people they're scary but
stacey abrams went on cnn to explain why
she took the mask off and left the kids
masked
i took the mask off because i was
speaking remotely to two other
classrooms and i wanted all of them to
hear me
oh she just wanted people to hear her so
it was cool if maybe she was going to
transmit the deadly virus that
everyone's freaking out over for the
last two years it's totally cool she
just wanted people to hear nobody
nobody could hear what you're saying but
you know so she just you know in the
interest of having other classrooms that
were watching on skype hear her she
could transmit her evil deadly germs and
in that case it would be okay because
obviously she has a lot of seriously
important stuff to say
all right it continues uh here is the
infallible fouchy a man who has gotten
almost all of this wrong from the
beginning who has contradicted himself
endlessly for two years who has sent
emails telling friends that they can go
on vacation and not wear masks while he
was telling us to double mask and a
whole bunch more he has been lambasted
and smacked around by one of our good
senators rand paul you guys have all
seen those videos here he is defending
the forced masking of children and what
about the debate over masks in illinois
schools dr fauci says he believes masks
and vaccinations are helping to keep
schools open before we start talking
about pulling back on them let's get
that dynamic of the virus in the
community low enough so that we can feel
safe in pulling back on the requirement
for children to wear masks
okay so this is just the endless drivel
that fauci has given us from day one
notice he never gives us the numbers we
have to get the dynamic low enough
something something something but they
never say what that low number would be
what the dynamic exactly would be they
never talk about how
99.998 or something like that percentage
of children uh you know survive covet
and all of that stuff and that natural
immunity works i know you know all of
this stuff so it's just this endless
drivel from this man and then what
happens is that dribble then starts
affecting teachers and administrators
and this true lunatic this is randy
weingarten who is the teachers union
president uh this past weekend talking
about why kids should still be in masks
what dr mcbride just told us about mass
not particularly being effective for
children what's the argument against
taking off masks in schools well the
argument is that you have well let me
just say this
i am in favor of an off ramp on mass
right the real issue becomes
are is the is
is the spread
low enough
so that there's no dissemination or
transmission in schools and it's not
the teachers transmitting to kids
it's more kids
and kids
particularly in elementary schools right
now and so the question really becomes
do we have that's why i like what
massachusetts has done because what
they've said is that on a school by
school basis they said if there's 80
percent vaccination rates then those
schools can lift the mandates
okay i want to be nice and not
hyperbolic or anything here that woman
is a
soulless wench
she is a liar okay she has forced all of
these school closures she is a
progressive activist
activist
masking as someone who is supposed to be
running this the the teachers unions to
keep schools open and make sure our kids
are educated but what she really is is a
progressive activist that's all that she
is she said something there that is
completely
insane she said the real issue is the
spread is low enough for no
dissemination
it is impossible
it is literally impossible that zero
people children adult whatever will
neither get kovid nor transmit covid
in the old days when i was a kid
sometimes there'd be a sick kid at
school and he'd go to the nurse and then
he'd go home
and maybe another kid got sick or maybe
a teacher got sick and maybe they
wouldn't come to school the next day but
there was no there was no concept of
zero covid that no one will ever get
anything that we will sit in
hermetically sealed boxes and be
perfectly safe from everything that is
counter to what life is all about so you
can see that these people just lie about
everything these are the same people
let's not forget last week eric garcetti
the mayor of los angeles who said he
holds his breath when he takes pictures
of people lying [ __ ] artist
gavin newsom the the psychopath running
the once great state of california who
said that he wore his mask except when
he was drinking water at the football
game except there's plenty of video that
he didn't and i don't have to go into
the hypocrisy about it him and i guess i
now have to throw in five dollars
because i mentioned california let's say
we're up to 150 every time i throw in
five it becomes 25 but it's all right um
anyway what i said at the top of the
show is really what i want to focus on
right now because it's not just the
hypocrisy right
they're doing the hypocrisy
intentionally they want to show you that
they rule over you that's why aoc goes
to events in 50 000
gowns while all of the staff is wearing
masks and she is not they want to show
you they are better than you they
control you and you better be afraid of
them i think you all understand that now
but i want what i want to focus on today
because this is where it's now shifting
is that the narrative
is actually moving in real time we have
seen it in the last 24 or 48 hours where
suddenly
oh masks maybe they're not great maybe
uh we should open up things maybe we've
been really the ones saying this the
whole time this is cnn's leanna wen she
is one of their medical correspondents
she's the former president of planned
parenthood that's just an interesting
tidbit of information there
and we've got a
bit of a compilation of her on how the
science has changed do you agree with
the move
i do there was a and is a time and place
for pandemic restrictions but when they
were put in it was always with the
understanding that they would be removed
as soon as we can and in this case
circumstances have changed case counts
are declining also the science has
changed we know that vaccines protect
very well against omicron which is the
dominant variant everyone five and older
have widespread access to vaccines and
we also know about one way masking the
idea that even if other people around
you are not wearing masks if you wear a
high quality mask that also protects you
the wearer too and so in this case i'm
not saying i don't think anyone really
is saying that no one should ever wear
masks but rather that the responsibility
should shift from a government mandate
imposed from the state or the local
district of the school rather it should
shift to an individual responsibility by
the family who can still decide that
their child can wear a mask if needed
man that is just extraordinary i'm not
for gulags for my political opponents
but i i don't know what you do with
someone like her i mean that is
profoundly evil she has been pushing
mandates she has been pushing masks the
idea that everyone has to wear them now
she's saying you can wear too and they
shouldn't have to do it also the science
has changed no the science hasn't
changed and this idea that suddenly oh
now we know that the the vaccines work
on omicron two weeks ago they were
telling us it didn't work on omicron and
that's why everybody was getting covet
over over christmas in the new and new
years and everything else so now here's
the compilation of her saying completely
the opposite over the past two years one
other thing that we're seeing now and i
think this is a response to the rise of
delta is more willingness among
governmental authorities and others to
mandate the vaccine we saw that
yesterday the va said it's going to
require the vaccine for its employees we
saw the mayor of new york the governor
of california do you anticipate seeing
more in this vein more requirements
yes and it cannot come soon enough you
can remain unvaccinated if you so choose
but if you want to be in public and
potentially could be infecting others
with a dangerous and sometimes fatal
disease that's highly transmissible
then
there's an obligation of society i mean
i think you could have an opt-out the
way that france for example or italy and
other countries are doing saying that if
you want to be in bars restaurants movie
theaters etc either be vaccinated or
have proof of a recent negative test i
hope that we move in that direction as a
country here because at the end of the
day i don't really understand why people
have the choice to be infecting um our
vulnerable children or
immuno-compromised people or even others
who have taken the responsible choice to
get vaccinated sure and i just first
want to clarify that i was opposed to
the ccc
back in may when they
lifted the indoor mass requirement i
thought that the honor code was never
going to work that when vaccinated and
unvaccinated people are mixing unless
there is proof of vaccination everybody
should still be wearing masks and so i
actually support what the cdc is now
doing which is going back to this indoor
mask requirement because frankly we know
that we can't trust the unvaccinated
that they have been walking around
without masks and in fact that's what
led to the surge that we're seeing
vaccine is the ticket back to
pre-pandemic life and the window to do
that is really narrowing i mean you were
mentioning chris about how all these
states are reopening they're reopening
at a hundred percent and we have a very
narrow window to tie reopening policy to
vaccination status because otherwise if
everything is reopened then what's the
carrot going to be how are we going to
incentivize people to actually get the
vaccine so that's why i think the cdc
and the obama administration needs to
come out a lot bolder and say if you're
vaccinated you can do all these things
here all these freedoms that you have
because otherwise people are going to go
out and enjoy these freedoms anyway
if you need a moment to grab a bucket
and puke
maybe i could pause for just a second
because she's disgusting absolutely
disgusting there is so much it's not
just that it's dishonesty in there and
and this deep like desire to control
people but the way she says it i don't
understand why people have choice that's
what she said i don't understand why
people have the choice
i understand because in america you got
choice lady okay that's number one then
at the end what's the carrot if you open
up everything she's telling you we are
the government and she's she's a
government agent she's not a she's not a
journalist even though they put her on
the clown network cnn what is the carrot
if we let them do things mean meaning if
we just give them freedom which they
think they give us right which they
don't give us but they think they give
it to us and actually the more that we
let them
believe that the more that they'll keep
taking uh then then why why would they
do what we want if they've already got
the carrot
right because rabbits like carrots and
rabbits usually uh when they're
domesticated live in little cages and
that's what they would love for us so
this woman is an extraordinary liar what
she's realizing right now and what cnn
and this is what i taught what i'm
saying about the narrative shift they're
all realizing that everyone really hates
the democrats right now and you really
should you really should i mean that
these people have destroyed lives
they have they have broken our education
system
they have caused depression and drug use
to skyrocket they have destroyed our
cities
the the damage that has been done
because of democrat policies all of
these people cheered on by the media who
are just democrats on television um the
damage that has been done will be
two generations
easily the i knew it you go back to the
videos that i was doing two weeks after
covet i did the two week thing we all
did the two week thing and then i
started saying you know the old world
ain't coming back it's pretty obvious
it's pretty obvious and those people
have killed the old world and they are
trying to condition us to a new world
that is going to be much worse okay much
worse so now here's another democrat
this is representative hakeem jeffries
from new york and you're not going to
believe who's who who is he crediting
you're not going to believe it because
the states are going to start opening up
now kind of doing what florida's been
doing all along doing what texas has
kind of been doing and tennessee's been
doing and all those scary red states
have been doing who's he crediting now
that the blue states are going to open
up because they want to win in the
midterms
yeah he's crediting brandon take a look
and the omicron variant is in retreat
and that's not by accident
that's because under president biden's
leadership a public health
infrastructure was put into place
beginning with the american rescue plan
without a single republican vote
to ensure
that we can do everything possible to
crush the virus and that is what has
been happening
i'm going to have to start drinking in
the middle of the day
i really am i don't like day drinking i
know a lot of people like to day drink
even on the weekends never been a fan
okay
i like drinking when it's dark out but
the extraordinary level of lies it's
thanks to to joe biden that omicron is
in retreat no it isn't it's because the
vaccines did not work the way that joe
biden and leanna wen and fauci and
wilenski and all of you collection of
elitist liars pushed on us it didn't
work that way and guess what happened
over christmas and into the new year
everyone basically got omicron or got
some variant of covid including yours
truly and i did have leg pains for three
days and then i took the monoclonal
treatment which was easily accessible
here in florida which now the federal
government has stopped i took ivermectin
which isn't just a horse paste and yes i
was okay in three days and some people
were a little more sick david was a
little more sick
my brother got it at the exact same same
time as me he wasn't really sick i
wasn't really sick i'm not vaccinated he
is everyone made choices for themselves
it has nothing absolutely nothing to do
with the policies of these people and
let's not forget i wish we would have
grabbed the clip uh let's not forget
what joe biden said uh what was it right
around thanksgiving about how the winter
is going to be a winter of death for the
unvaccinated huh didn't really come to
pass did it could it just be that you're
a fear-mongering lunatic who just reads
off the teleprompter whatever they put
in front of you well you know what's
happening
you know what's happening at this very
minute we've been covering it here
you're probably not seeing it on
mainstream media there actually is a
shift there is a shift because good
decent people from the bottom up are
starting to fight back and it's
happening in all places in the world
it's happening in canada and we know all
about the the trucker convoy i'm to do a
little bit more on that
in just a few minutes but now the
premier of alberta jason kinney is
dropping restrictions because people
peacefully protested because they
exercise their rights that they have in
a western free democracy and they stood
up to the fraudulent
the fraudulent chronic liar that is
justin trudeau take a look the threat of
covet 19
to public health is
no longer outweighs
the hugely damaging impact of health
restrictions on our society on people's
mental health on their emotional
well-being on uh
our broader social health
so now is the time to begin learning to
live with kovic
these restrictions have led to terrible
division
even amongst families and friends
and uh inflamed sometimes tensions in
our communities and neighborhoods uh
covet and the restrictions associated
with it have robbed thousands of young
children with the simple joys of just
being a kid
guys
guys do you think it's a coincidence
that he's saying this now or do you
think it might have something to do
with groups of individual people
fighting back
saying no
you don't own us we are going to take
our lives in our own hands we are going
to join together and fight for what's
right which is what they're doing and
they're doing it freaking peacefully and
they're doing it all over the nation not
just in alberta not just in ottawa uh
we've got some some video of the convoy
right here let's take a look at that i
mean it's just look at that that is
absolutely extraordinary what they are
doing those are thousands of good people
who are not out there because they hate
trans people or have an irrational fear
i should say they have an irrational
fear of trans people and that's why
they're out there in the convoy that's
literally what trudeau said and tweeted
they have an
illegitimate fear of muslims and that's
why they're out there they're white
supremacists
god these people the gall like what i
don't know what could have happened to
the human soul that could lead them to
that place but it's not just justin
trudeau who's soulless it really is not
you all know
my favorite lady over in dc
jen soccer
she's lying about what's happening up in
canada take a look
so truckers in canada last night shut
down the ambassador bridge which carries
about a quarter of us canada
trading goods
so what's the administration's response
to this action and what steps are being
taken to ensure the free flow of goods
and also
any preventative steps being taken to
address a possible blockade on the
michigan side of that bridge well let me
first start by saying i know there's
been some suggestion not by reporters
necessarily at all but that
this congestion is related to the
vaccine requirements it's not uh i mean
i i'm saying i'm going to get to the
protests but the protests uh going on
across canada which have spread to a
bridge are leading to sporadic
congestion and blockages
all right first off i want to give her
credit because she's actually dressed
like a witch and it's like a little on
the nose so good for you saki um now
interestingly as per what she said there
about the truckers and what's happening
there's this guy up in canada who
actually
completely disagrees with her
i think one of the things
we all understand is just how frustrated
everyone is
we're all frustrated we're all sick and
tired of restrictions of of mandates of
having to to make sacrifices of not
being able to do the things we love
i can understand frustrations with
mandates but mandates are the way to
avoid further restrictions or having to
be restricted as people get vaccinated
as canadians have gotten vaccinated
we've been able to get through things
and this team is going to stay focused
on doing exactly that
we're all so frustrated nobody know how
this thing happened we don't know we
mandates are the way to freedom well i
don't know who did this who's in charge
around here i just have nice hair and i
wear nice socks and people think that
i'm a really nice guy even though i'm an
evil [ __ ] okay so i don't know how any
of this happened
here's trudeau saying the complete
opposite individuals
are trying to blockade
our economy
our democracy
and our fellow citizens daily lives
it has to stop
freaking individuals
is there anything worse than individuals
you know peacefully doing stuff and
saying that uh we're not going to bow to
the king is there anything worse
cleaning up garbage shoveling snow
helping old people across the street is
there anything worse than individuals
well it's not just justin trudeau i i
like that justin trudeau impression what
do you think it's pretty good
i don't know how this happened it was i
was somebody told me that something was
happening i you know i talk like this so
it seems like i'm not evil or that i
don't have bad intentions but i'm really
a frighteningly horrible person um
it's not just justin trudeau though who
is lying flat out lying about the
intentions and the motives and the
actual reality on the ground that the
truckers are doing
it's all of our mainstream media we've
got quite a compilation for you
sedition insurrection a threat to
democracy this city is under siege they
are now calling it an occupation an
alarming situation there in ottawa the
police chief is calling it a nationwide
insurrection driven by madness this is
kind of our insurrection by air horn
moment it's i think it's part of the
globalization of trumpism canadians know
where i stand there hasn't been as much
violence as some had perhaps projected
but that does not necessarily mean that
it has been peaceful reports of severe
vandalism and criminal behavior streets
are clogged the honking is incessant and
deafening this pandemic has sucked
for all canadians residents that i have
spoken to who say they feel terrorized
intimidated residents say they feel like
hostages residents in that area say that
they are being held hostage that this
freedom has essentially this freedom
convoy as they call it has essentially
imposed a lockdown on them some
protesters harassed a soup kitchen these
anti-vaxxers actually took food from the
mouths of the homeless hungry yeah
because they were they're they're so put
upon there have not been any violent
outbursts however horns have been
honking for 12 to 21 hours a night the
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable
views that they're expressing many of
them are holding confederate flags i've
heard there's q anon supporters in the
crowd we've seen swastikas we've seen
the confederate flag we've seen a flags
with justin trudeau our prime minister
in a noose uh lots of donald trump flags
as well people chanting let's go brandon
it is actually one of the rare times in
history you're gonna see swastikas and
yellow stars at the same protest
what is
a human
what is a human being like what are
those people doing
i can accept that a certain amount of
them are brainwashed and i can accept
that a certain amount of them just want
a gig that it's nice to be on tv
they put makeup on you you know it's
nice they do your hair they might give
you clothes
i do my own hair they do whack me with
powder i pick out my own clothes
um but these people have sold their
souls i don't know what how else can you
describe human beings
who lie
as their main ethos the main driver of
what they do is to lie about people
i i don't know how else you can describe
it
they want there to be violence you could
that one woman out there hasn't been on
violence really and you know there's
swastikas and there's we don't see any
images of any of this they showed one
confederate flag there's trump signs
everywhere haven't seen those but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's something
bad
these people are evil and just juxtapose
that with how they treated the actually
violent riots that we had all over the
united states of america for the last
two years except you know it was odd
i have to look into this why did all of
those race riots stop the second that
joe biden became president did we solve
racism did we solve the policing thing
and all the systemic stuff and all that
stuff do we solve all that or could it
be that that's actually the democrats
and the media working together to
destroy trump and then they you know
they stop it when they need it to be
stopped and you know then their guy was
in power
crazy right um
these are bad people they did not cover
as a matter of fact they would either
ignore the violence when they were
attacking the federal courthouse in
portland when they were burning down
buildings or they would
obfuscate it in such a way that you
wouldn't understand who was doing the
violence so cities would be burning
cities in uh wisconsin cities
minneapolis like you've all seen the
stuff i mean you know right now go to
new york city watch watch people just
walk in and steal a whole bunch of stuff
out of cvs you can do whatever you want
in these cities the drugs that are
everywhere but those are peaceful things
where i used to live in los angeles when
they took all of ventura boulevard and
they had to blockade all of the
restaurants and all of the shops there
the mom and pop shops and they had to
put blm on them and they were doing it
because they loved blm so much or was
that it was their hostage situation
we're we we know you guys are the
tolerant ones and that's why we're
boarding up our windows and saying that
we love you because you guys are
tolerant you guys are the good guys
everything is backwards people it is
your job as a as a thinking free person
to fight for what's right right now
because they're coming and they're doing
it you have to admire it this is the
matrix this is the machine in the matrix
they're somehow always one step ahead of
us i don't know how they do it i really
don't and i kind of admire it i'd like
to figure it out but you cannot forget
who got us here and how they got us here
okay you cannot forget and you must
remember when you vote and i can only
imagine the shenanigans they're going to
come up with since and how they'll try
to link the truckers further with the
the january sixth insurrection and god
knows what they will do god knows what
they will do until this election like
it's really really crazy but stop
letting these people abuse your children
because that's what they're doing that's
what they're doing uh stacy abrams who
who believes in election fraud when when
she loses and she's allowed to talk
about it and be treated as a hero again
i have no idea why anyone knows who she
is other than she contested uh the
election in georgia right nobody knows
who she is or why she's there you know
nobody knows but they she's she's a
child abuser what else are you other
than that when you gleefully can get the
image one more time you grieffully look
at her look at her there's only one
person in that room who maybe maybe
is is in risk of covid and it's her and
she's the one not wearing the mess but
why did she do well because they had to
hear me
i don't like these people very much
that's the show oh no that's not the
show for today we gotta if you i hope
you enjoyed the show today i enjoyed
doing the show today but we got a real
outro for you uh that daily wire put
together but before i get to that a
couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com and appreciate
you all you guys who are in the comment
section as we're doing the show live
hawk says science changes ah so it's not
settled
great point hawk great point we're
always told science is settled until
they unsettle it and now it's settled
with their new settling or something
like that
awful leeanne when you were a terrible
terrible human
russell says they always bring the
narrative back to vaccines and
completely leave out the fact that you
can still transmit covid with it you can
get covid with the vaccine you can
transmit covid with the vaccine i was
booted from twitter for saying that back
in july
candice says omicron will go away and we
will be back to the common cold just in
time for midterms yes that's what this
is all about that's what this is all
about they are looking at internal
polling
and they are saying holy
[ __ ] we overstepped maybe abusing
people's children for two years was a
bit much
maybe destroying everyone's lives lives
was a bit much
maybe look at the rate of drug use and
depression and boy maybe it had
something to do with us
we better do something about that but
now the thing that you need to know is
that the machine will now do something
with that the media the democrats the
entire machine is somehow over the next
six months going to make it seem like
the republicans were the ones locking
people down and it was the good
democrats like stacey abrams who were
trying to save us
from the evil republicans that's what's
on the way know it just know that and
don't forget that and then i think you
can you can think clearly about the
issues going forward uh so to end
today's show and i hope you enjoyed
another one of these narrative shows i i
dig this i think we're gonna we're gonna
keep doing more of these uh the daily
wire put together a spectacular
spectacular
destruction of the mainstream media and
why these clowns and that's what they
are
why these clowns in suits should not be
trusted i'll see you tomorrow
this brand new research by gallup says
american trust in the mass media is at
its lowest point since 2016 and near a
record low overall jeff zucker has
announced his immediate resignation as
the president of cnn this comes amid an
investigation into what jeff zucker
calls a consensual relationship what
happened and where cnn goes from here
you were caught masturbating on camera
you since then have been on leave from
cnn do i have all that right um you got
it all right sad to say the biggest
media story this weekend it's the firing
of chris cuomo from this network cnn
late wednesday a lawyer contacted cnn
with a sexual misconduct complaint about
cuomo joining me now the man who accused
don lemon of sexual assault his accuser
claims lemon started rubbing himself but
the even bigger point i think is about
what the press is is it produced by
reporters or by repeaters repeaters are
the talk radio shouters they're on tv
and radio telling the same story every
day president trump president trump
president trump trump trump trump trump
trump trump trump trump trump donald
trump donald trump telling the same
story every day repeaters are twitter
trolls who anonymously amplify
propaganda and try to wear the rest of
us down with their repetition january 6
january 6 january 6th january 6th
january 6th to january 6th january 6th
january 6th repetition the january 6
insurrection the insurrection the
insurrection insurrection
so much of what they are repeating is
from reporters from the people paid to
figure out what is true a widely held
conspiracy theory that the coronavirus
was created in the chinese laboratory dr
fauci thank you for keeping it straight
thank you for fighting the good fight we
know the science we know that mass work
what we have now
is a pandemic of the unvaccinated this
is really now a pandemic of the
unvaccinated this is now a pandemic of
the unvaccinated this is now a pandemic
of the unvaccinated this is now a
pandemic
much of the dossier has been
corroborated what does putin have on
trump has trump been compromised but it
does look like that young man to me is
taunting the native american vietnam vet
and he's in his face there is no
evidence of any wrongdoing by either
hunter or joe biden there's no evidence
of wrongdoing by either joe or hunter
biden what you're seeing behind me is
one of multiple locations that have been
burning and kenosha this isn't about
ideology the biggest terror threat in
this country comes from radicals on the
far right primarily white men as a white
woman aware of my own privilege in this
country i am so angry and i can't even
begin
now too many see the protests as the
problem no the problem is what forced
your fellow citizens to take to the
streets a few moments later we're here
inside cnn center i just threw something
on fire
nick you all right we're getting out of
here chris all right we are not fake
news we are real news now the two faces
of hillary clinton are coming out the
fact through wikileaks that she says one
thing
uh and
oh no all right let's see if we can get
congressman collins back obviously we
just lost the satellite feed that sucks
routinely at these rallies we are
hearing a chance of cnn sucks
this is cnn the most trusted name
[Applause]
cnn sucks man